are you watching right now what's your
what's your change
what are your zoom shows I'm watching
okay what we are we're watching so much
TV Morty oh my god wait I'm gonna tell
you something almost embarrassing
we are watching so much TV during the
day that we like blacked out the windows
in our that's shameful that's true yeah
that's a little scary
that's a let's tell anybody about that
okay don't worry no one will see this we
we binge Succession right we binge
unorthodox we binge Tiger King and all
that stuff um we okay here's here's a
fun thing we've been doing every single
night during dinner time we watch one
episode of Cheers
did you did you watch tears I mean you
would be too young I'm so young that's
really true but um I'm serious I mean
what I'm saying is Cheers
is there are a lot of actors out there
of a different generation that didn't
watch that show when it was on we know
it from reruns right that's true I mean
III do remember when it was on the air I
remember my my parents loved it in my
grandma I loved it and she had a big Ted
Danson crush god rest her soul she's
about she's upstairs at your house
yes she's if I had a camera would show
her she's strapped to the ceiling and
she's fine
hi grandma Nita she's fine she's um so
yeah we we I didn't really watch it when
it was I I didn't
there was no like kids on the show it
was all like sexy adults and I didn't
quite like you were watching silver
spoons or something you know I didn't
get enough silver spoons punky brewster
etc beans Baxter I think I made that up
yeah anyway doing right now right that
show Conan okay beans Baxter there was a
beans Baxter I think and I think it was
a kids show but let's move on okay and
gets the essential point if you
watching cheers and here's the crazy
thing your castmates on the good place
with Ted Danson other incarnation of Ted
Danson it's so strange
it's so like surreal I told I told the
rest of the cast all the other all the
other four of them to watch it now after
having spent four years you know working
with and loving Ted Danson it's such an
interesting thing to go back and watch
the show that sort of made him who he is
yeah quick Conan's epic it's okay oh my
god those are loud swallows I'm just
telling you I think I could hear it
cartilage you know this other Ted Danson
dislike so her hair Jack no Ted Danson
and then you see him as Sam Malone yeah
for the first time that's new eyes and
it's so funny I mean he's you know
everybody knows Ted Danson's hot as hell
that is no secret right you know it I
know it I'm no I'm not gonna go on with
that oh go ahead I think well okay um
but he's like a different level of sexy
he's like a sexy he's sexy on cheers
he's like he defined the word sexy he's
like making out with Shelly wrong and
it's so strange for me it truly feels
like um like when you see your parents
make out or something because I will be
watching it and I'll be like Oh Ted stop
gross please just watch the show right
right I love that you said it's like
it's like Conan like when you watch your
parents make out I've never seen that in
my life well your eyes didn't we know
when I'm dead inside
[Laughter]
your creepy little freaking creep Darcy
my bestie Jason and I hope you guys are
doing great thanks for
me I've also heard a lot of nice stuff
about the podcast a lot of people liked
it oh my god people loved it
I've got so many amazing comments about
thank you for doing it anything okay you
know shooting a really weird movie and
you're in it now okay great
I I commit you're right goodbye the
little creep I'll talk to you later
let's start drinking you can start in
like two hours yeah
or even just like a half hour all right
cool
all right we'll see you later